you guys ever stolen your parents credit
cards for anything on your
kids oh okay my mom would find out so
[ __ ] fast bro my mom checks her
credit card like daily
for like there was absolutely no way i
didn't do it i didn't even know where my
credit card was no no to me money wasn't
a system where you could
i never viewed it as a system where you
could game it i always thought of this i
get money
i spend the money that i get yeah yeah
like i and i could i could earn money
through things that was
i never even conceived like i'm not
saying this i think i'm like i'm a good
boy
i literally never even conceived of the
fact that i could take money
that's not even a good boy thing that's
just a boy thing like that yeah i just
have to be common sense i just assumed
the only way to get it was through doing
the tasks that i was allotted maybe
because i played video games too much
and i thought
task equals reward i i genuinely
never even considered so when i hear
about these kids who steal their credit
parents credit cards
how is this so [ __ ] normalized like
to me it was never even an option
yeah of like when i hear that i'm just
like okay you're like a nine-year-old 10
year old who just happened to get their
mom's credit card like
how did you find that yeah like i would
if i was a nine-year-old and i was like
man i really want to like throw a super
chat at this v tuber i'm not gonna think
like
where's my where's my mom's credit card
like i'm not gonna like start thinking
like i was like all right let's start
the simulation
where could my mom's credit card
possibly be in this house
snake music starts like i wouldn't even
think about that right i would rather
i'd have more luck
trying to trick my parents by convincing
them yeah yeah yeah exactly like
i think i probably have done that before
more than that you don't understand
they're like my favorite vegans
the ones that put the details in and
they don't like it well you
you're amateurs 10 10 year olds nowadays
are too lazy you know i need to i should
make guides
but you've got a [ __ ]
more kids need to be like darren brown
like the [ __ ] big brain like
yeah convincing like don't steal
convince other people to steal for you
that's what you should be isn't this
like proxy bullying yeah
yeah yeah